new research aimed at understanding the
impact of social media on adolescent
brains is already showing fascinating
the results the National Institutes of
Health study is following more than
11,000 children over a decade in early
testing researchers found significant
differences in brain chemistry for kids
who had at least seven hours of screen
time a day compared to kids who use
screens less Anderson Cooper spoke to
the researchers for last night 60
minutes until recently it was impossible
to see what happens inside a young brain
when a person is focused on a mobile
device but now scientists at the
University of California San Diego have
hacked that problem how often do you
have young people come in for the MRIs
so as often as we possibly can dr. Cara
baguette is an investigator on that 300
million dollar NIH study her team is
scanning teenagers brains as they follow
Instagram the most popular social media
app when we met 18-year old Roxy Shemp
she was about to participate in dr.
Baggett study how much some do you
actually spend on screens I check my
phone pretty regularly I'd say what's
pretty regularly every at least 10 to 20
minutes is that a conservative estimate
probably she can't take her phone into
the MRI because of the powerful magnets
in the machine so a mirror has been
placed above her face to allow her to
look across the room at a movie screen
displaying images from her Instagram
account this way dr. Baggett can see
exactly which parts of the brain's
reward system are most active while
using social media so you can actually
see a part of the brain light up when
you're feeling good yes from the scanner
in the scanner yeah
based on her data and the results from
other studies dr. Baggett is among
scientists who believe screen time
stimulates the release of the brain
chemical dopamine which has a pivotal
role in cravings and desire so you're
more likely to act impulsively and use
social media compulsively instead of
like checking yourself you want to keep
on it to keep getting the good feelings
psychologists and best-selling author
Lisa d'amour is a CBS News contributor
and it's here with more on this Lisa
good morning good morning so we won't
know the full results from this study
for quite a while but does anything
concern you from what we see thus far
well here's what we do know we do know
that social media is incredibly
compelling we know that it triggers the
reward centers in the brain and this is
true from grown-ups too not just
teenagers and kids so we know that we
also know that digital technology
already disrupts things that are
important for healthy development so
sleep one-on-one interactions that are
face-to-face learning how to focus on
one's schoolwork physical activity so we
should already start to be drawing some
minds around digital technology just to
protect normal and healthy development
and so much is about guidelines we know
that now pediatricians recommend the
children under the age of two not have
any screen time what are the guidelines
for children up through adolescence
though I think that the way we want to
think about it is that there's no simple
answer right that we wish there were I
recommend that we really make priorities
about what are we trying to protect so
we're trying to protect sleep we're
trying to protect family time we're
trying to protect focus so I think the
guidelines should flow from there
children need a lot more sleep than
people appreciate elementary school
children need 11 hours a night middle
schoolers need 10 hours a night high
schoolers need 9 hours a night so if we
even do that that's one heck of a
guideline and the thing is it's not just
total time it's that we're creating a
habit of distractions we're training our
kids to keep interrupting themselves
which means they can't do anything hard
because they seek that interruption
that's right focus is a muscle that we
build and it doesn't matter if someone
interrupts you or you interrupt yourself
it still disrupts your focus you have a
new book coming out about anxiety and
depression specifically among young
girls how does social media contribute
to that is there data that shows that
it's causal we don't yet have causal
data but what we do have are some
longitudinal studies that have actually
looked at the trajectory through sleep
that when high schoolers get phones that
disrupt their sleep subsequently they go
on to have higher rates of depression
higher rates of emotional fragility so
we don't you
have a certain knee but we are in that
door I mean I hear this from parents all
the time suicide rates being up they
know someone that their kids go to
school with depression anxiety what's
causing that I think we don't really
know and I think simple answers are
appealing but they're probably not
accurate we want to look at this in
broad scope and think about a lot of
factors that may be causing stress and
anxiety to go up for our kids and making
it important that we take steps to
protect them
from a lot of things social media may be
one of them and since I've already read
an early copy of her book I know there's
a lot of answers
February 12 anyway and with teenage kids
who sees those weather patterns of their
moods change quickly you know that
social media is playing a little bit of
a role he said the more thank you so
much you're welcome this thanks for
having me